- Professor Steve Girvin, for those of you
who don't know him, just
a legendary professor
here at Yale and someone who's
been a great partner to us
in terms of YQI and its connections
to the Schmidt Program at Jackson.
He's Yale's Eugene Higgins
Professor of Physics and Applied Physics.
He's previously served as
Deputy Provost to the University
for Science and Technology,
Deputy Provost for Research,
and his scholarship has
focused on theoretical studies
of quantum, many particle systems,
interests in atomic physics,
quantum optics, quantum computation,
and in addition to teaching at Yale,
he has served as the founding Director
of Brookhaven National
Laboratories Co-Design Center
for Quantum Advantage, where
he remains an active member,
and this is a major national effort
funded by the Department of Energy
to accelerate transformational advances
in quantum science and to
build the tools necessary
to create scalable
quantum computer systems,
so in terms of what that
means for global affairs.
And very delighted to
hand it over to Steve
to introduce other colleagues.
I know we have some folks here
from Professor Shruti
Puri's class as well,
so welcome to all of you,
and I think this will be a fun session,
so appreciate it, Steve.
- Thank you very much.
This is, I hope this will be fun.
So, I have some help.
Shraddha Singh is a graduate student
with me and Shruti Puri.
Kevin Smith and Dan Price post-docs,
and we have some physicists
here from Shruti's class.
And so the first thing is the,
you know, the most important
sentence you can learn
as a scientist and to succeed
is I don't understand.
So, you know, we talk
this stuff every day.
We have like kind of
inside baseball lingo.
If I accidentally use
some or quantum mechanics
is just too strange for you,
stick your hand up and say,
I don't understand, and we
have time and I wanna, I,
you know, I'd rather uncover
a little than cover a lot.
And so I also promise we
won't talk about this stuff.
(room laughs)
And please, you know,
just don't be shy and please interrupt.
So I thought I'd, the way
this is gonna work is,
or we hope it's gonna
work, is I'll give a,
I have a slide deck and the
first part is just kinda,
you know, what's quantum about
and what's going on these days,
and then we're gonna talk
about a specific protocol
for encrypting communications in a way
that can't be broken without
violating the laws of physics,
so it's a physical-based encryption,
and we're gonna, you have some handouts,
we're gonna do some little exercises,
so I'll say some stuff
that'll sound complicated
and you'll get a chance to practice it,
it'll seem easy, then
we'll move on, I hope.
That's the plan, okay?
So there's, you know, there's a sort of
second quantum revolution
going on right now,
and I want to just give you a
little background about that.
So first, I have a few
places where I say vocabulary
just to make sure I'm using words
in a way that you understand,
and so when we say classical mechanics,
we mean the things that
Galileo and Newton did
in the late 1600s, and it's
an extremely successful theory
of mechanical motions of
the moon, of falling apples,
footballs, planets, and
when I say quantum mechanics
or the quantum theory,
that's a more complete theory
invented in the 20th century
that explains all of this,
but this fails for very small objects,
and quantum theory applies to tiny objects
like atoms and electrons
and individual particles
of light, photons, okay?
And so quantum theory is
the single most successful
theory in all of the physical sciences.
A theory is, you know, you have
evolution debates, you know,
theory is actually the highest
adjective, not the lowest.
It means that it's been
fully confirmed by experiment
with many, many digits of accuracy.
So, quantum theory describes
behavior at atomic scales
and now larger scales,
even millimeter scales
in some of the qubits,
the quantum bits that we build,
and it's an extremely
strange and mysterious
and counterintuitive picture of the world
in which you have to use language
like particles act like and
waves act like particles,
and they're very counterintuitive
effects that the,
you can prepare exactly
the same experiment over
and over again and get different
random results each time,
even though it's exactly the same.
There's a certain built-in
ineluctable randomness
in the results, and
then there's this thing
that Einstein hated,
spooky action at a distance,
entanglement, for which the,
was discovered a long time ago,
but for which really solid
experiments have only been done
in the last 40 years and are the subject
of this year's Nobel Prize in Physics.
So Einstein, you know,
invented a lot of the ideas
of quantum mechanics, but he hated it,
and he couldn't deal, he
just couldn't stand the fact
that there should be
non-deterministic results,
there should be ineluctable randomness,
and he said, "God does not play dice,"
but modern physicists
like to say that the irony
is that it was Einstein
who gave God the dice.
He really gave us a lot of the ideas
that founded the quantum theory.
So the first quantum revolution,
the sort of invention
of the quantum theory,
beginning more than 100 years ago,
people were, physicists were just thinking
about very basic things
about reality and electrons
and atoms and light, and there were,
it's just curiosity-driven
fundamental research.
I want to put a plug in that
for you future policy leaders.
There were no conceivable applications
for these kind of things,
thinking about things that were invisible,
tiny atoms and so forth,
and yet it led to the
technological revolution
of the 20th century.
It led to the transistor, the laser,
the atomic clock,
which in turn led to the
global positioning system.
And the inventors of quantum
mechanics did not foresee
these quantum devices, and even
the more practical engineers
who invented these quantum devices
did not foresee their
applications, which are,
you know, all around you
and yet invisible, right?
So, you know, here's a picture
of Charlie Townes in 1953
with this big, clunky physics experiment
that was one of the
first atomic clocks that,
it's hard to imagine that today, you know,
I hold in my hand a gadget that knows,
by listening to transmissions
from satellites,
where it is on the, what time it is
to about a nanosecond and
where it is on the Earth
to a few meters of precision.
It's just incredible.
There's the first transistor, 1947.
It was about this big.
You can see beautiful
blobs of solder and wires,
and it's incredibly ugly, and
those people who invented that
could not foresee this and the,
you know, the central processing
unit in your computer,
and they certainly could not foresee
the number of transistors being
produced in the world today.
Any idea how many transistors are made
in one second every day of every year?
More than 20 trillion
transistors per second.
It's a good thing they're small.
(room laughs)
Otherwise we'd run out of stuff.
So, you know, the scaling
from one at a centimeter scale
to 20, you know, there's
about roughly 20 billion
in an iPhone.
Depending on how you count, even more.
It's just amazing and
very hard to foresee,
so we hope that this same
thing is going to happen
with the second quantum revolution,
but we have a long, long way to go.
So, we've recently come to understand
that these quantum devices
aren't very quantum.
They don't have the full power
that's available to quantum machines,
and in particular, there's
much more power for processing
and communicating
information than we realized,
and so the new idea which is driving
this second quantum revolution
is that the very strangest
aspects of quantum theory,
this uncertainty and randomness,
which I'll show you some
examples, they're not bugs.
Like, it seems like, to
a classical physicist,
oh, you do an experiment
exactly the same way every time
and you get a random result?
That seems bad.
I can't predict as well as I could before.
You can predict the probabilities
of different results,
but you can't predict the
results of any experiment.
It seems like a bug,
but in fact it can be a feature
that we can use in
technologies, and in fact,
that randomness is going
to be key to our quantum
encryption protocol that
we're gonna work through today
for securely transmitting information.
So this is a, I think
the final slide on this.
So there's this revolution underway.
I tried to explain,
we couldn't predict the
consequences of the first one,
so I don't think we can predict
the consequences of this one.
It has the potential to fizzle
out because the technology
is just too difficult at this
point, or it has the potential
to, you know, perhaps be as revolutionary
as the tech revolution
of the coming century.
And it involves sort of three things:
quantum materials with novel
properties, quantum sensing.
Measurement is a very important
part of quantum mechanics.
The role of an observer is special.
When you observe something, you change it.
That's gonna be part of our
encryption protocol also.
And we've learned much more about how to,
the ultimate limits of making
precision measurements,
and those are being used
both for fundamental physics,
things like seeing black hole mergers
producing tiny vibrations of spacetime,
which we can now measure,
and it's also the start, you know,
can be used in intelligence gathering.
You can use a thing which is
kind of like an atomic clock
to fly over a mountain
and see whether there's a tunnel inside
because there's less
gravity than you expect
because there's a tunnel there.
And then information
processing is very important,
and what's, a lot of what's
done in this institute
is centered around
quantum, building computers
based on the principles
of quantum mechanics,
but our discussion today is gonna be
about communication security and encrypt.
Okay, so the technology is not here yet.
We're in the very earliest days.
I wouldn't say we're in the
earliest part of the hype cycle,
but we're probably headed
for some troughs of disillusionment
before we finally get
this technology to work.
But lots and lots of
money is being invested
in these technologies now
because of their great potential.
Okay, so I'm gonna pause here.
We're gonna start our discussion
of the main topic today,
secure communication, but
maybe if you have questions now
about what I've said so
far, I'm happy to take them.
Yeah.
- [Student] So you were describing,
in the first quantum revolution,
that it was first
fundamental research with,
that was curiosity-driven,
and then applications have followed,
so in the second revolution,
is it following like, kind of a similar?
- Absolutely, yeah.
I mean the,
you know, the people that started thinking
about these questions
roughly 30 years ago were
theorists completely disconnected
to the realities of experiment,
and slowly they started
getting some interesting ideas,
other people started paying attention,
and then people started
thinking about, well,
maybe there's a way to
actually make these ideas
work in practice, and there's
just huge effort going on now,
making the technology better and better,
but still, we've made huge progress,
but we have a tremendous
way to go before it becomes,
let's say, economically or
important, but we're on
that same route, yeah.
Yeah.
- [Florian] Could you introduce yourself?
- [Michelle] My name's Michelle
and I'm a Jackson NAS student
for the one year program
in the Army, and for the concept
of flying over a mountain
and being able to detect the
different level of gravity,
you said, is there a
phrase that I could use
to research that in the future?
- You can probably try
gravitational anomaly.
I can send you the name of a
person that does that work.
- [Michelle] Thank you.
- Yeah.
- [Josh] Hi, Josh, second
year engineering student.
Can you explain like, how
transistors connect to quantum,
because my understanding is
that transistors are like,
binary, as kinda like different.
- Yeah, yeah, so,
transistors can encode classical.
I'm gonna talk about this, classical bits.
There are switches that can be on or off
or have a voltage or not have a voltage,
and that's how classical
bits are manipulated
in your computer.
I'm gonna talk about how quantum
bits are different, yeah.
Okay, all right, so some more vocabulary.
So the, when you write
a paper in communication
and encryption, you always use that Alice
is sending a message to Bob.
These are the terms of our field.
And there's an eavesdropper named Eve.
Okay, so the problem is
Alice has a secret message,
she wants to send it to Bob
over some communication channel,
radio, optical fiber, telephone, whatever,
and she wants to make sure
that Bob is the only person
in the world that gets the
message and knows what it says,
and the eavesdropper may have access,
you know, may, to pick an
example from the 1960s,
there may have been a submarine
that went into the Bering Sea
and may have dropped a
Bell Labs magnetometer
down around a little undersea cable
and may have picked up all the signals
from the magnetic fields
emanating from the
currents in those wires.
My uncle may have been on that boat.
(room laughs)
So there are ways to intercept the signals
and see what they are, so you have to,
you don't want to send them in plain text,
you want to encode them
in some secret code.
So, but before we start
talking about that,
we have to kind of define
and quantify what is information, okay?
Well, information is surprise.
If I tell you the sun rose this morning,
it's not much of a surprise, right?
The information is,
I tell you something you
didn't know before, okay?
And if I tell you the
answer to a yes/no question
that you didn't know before
and kind of prior to this,
you had no idea, you know,
you had just estimated
it's a 50/50 probability
I'm gonna hear yes or no,
that's receiving one bit of
information, binary digit,
and it can be represented by
a true or false or yes or no
or in a computer by a zero or a one, okay?
So you can,
another example is, and we
have some coins here today
we're going to be using,
we want them all back.
- [Florian] I have laundry to do,
so please don't steal them.
(room laughs)
- So Alice flips a coin,
which nobody knows whether
it's gonna land heads or tails.
When she reveals which it was,
that's one bit of information,
not necessarily a useful one,
but it's a bit of information.
If she tells, Bob gets one bit.
So a bit string is just a
collection of ones and zeros,
and in this case it's, it's a bite,
it contains eight bits of information.
Okay, so what can you do
with these bit strings?
Well, you could, if you
sent strings of five bits,
you could encode the alphabet
in, let's say in English,
so A could be all zeros, B
could be four zeros and a one,
C could be 00010.
Those of you that might
know about binary numbers,
those are the binary numbers
representing zero, one,
two, three, four, five.
You need five bits to
represent 32 characters,
so you've got the 26 letters
and you can do a few numbers also,
or you could have a code book.
There used to be, you know,
literally books on Navy ships
with different messages.
So here are some very famous
messages from history,
telegrams, and then you
could represent this message
by this bit string, 0000.
So, probably nobody here
knows where that comes from.
"The Italian navigator has
landed in the New World.
"The Natives are friendly."
It's not Columbus, it's
Enrico Fermi in Chicago,
got the first nuclear pile operating
in the Manhattan Project.
This was the telegram that
was sent to Washington.
So itself is encoded, right?
It's in English, but it's,
this was prearranged to mean
that the atomic pile worked.
Probably, you know what this is.
It's 50 years ago, okay,
landing on the moon.
And this is probably
easy to guess, but maybe,
Orville Wright sending a
telegram to his father in Ohio
saying they were coming home for Christmas
and the airplane worked.
Okay, so if you had such a big code book,
if it had 1,024 messages,
you only need 10 bits to encode them all,
because 10 digits can
represent all the numbers
between zero and 1,023.
If you had 20 bits,
you can send a million different messages.
It's very, very efficient,
okay, and as long as only Alice
and Bob have copies of the
code book, you're fine,
but of course, if people
start correlating the messages
with what they see, you
know, if there's a message
that's attack every time
they send bit strings,
you know, 1111, and there's an
attack at the following dawn,
you can kind of start to
guess what's going on,
so it's a very complicated
cat and mouse game
of offense and defense in signals.
Okay, so here's the transistor.
Rather than a transistor I have just a,
some mechanical switch, and you can store
one bit of information in
the position of the switch.
If the switch is off, so the
light bulb is not shining,
we'll call that zero.
If the switch is closed so that circuit,
the current can flow from the battery
through the light bulb,
we'll call that a one,
and you can transmit
that bit to other people
in the form of the light
coming from the light bulb,
so information is
physical, we like to say.
It's always transmitted,
stored in and transmitted
by physical systems.
So these, instead of
these mechanical switches,
you have electrical
switches that are controlled
by electricity in the form of transistors
in your computers.
Okay, so there's one provable,
provably secure method
in classical communication,
meaning with ordinary bits,
to do secure information transmission,
and that's the one-time pad
encryption using a random key.
So Alice and Bob have a
pad of paper and it had,
they flipped coins or something
and they have written down
a completely random string
of bits, zeros and ones.
They've also encoded
their English language,
plain text message as a
string of zeros and ones
that's called the plain text, there,
and then that text is encrypted
by the following rule.
If the key is zero, take the plain text
and just copy it down here.
If the key is one, copy the
opposite of what is here.
If it's a one, you put a zero.
If it's a zero, you put a one, okay?
So it's as if there are two ways to,
let's think of these as,
I don't know, yes and no.
There are two ways to encode yes and no.
Zero is yes, no is one
or the other way around,
and for each bit, Alice is flipping a coin
to decide which code to use.
So once you've done that, this
string is completely random.
There is no way that you can,
even if you intercept it,
no way to know what it means
unless you have this key.
So if Bob has, if Alice has this key
and Bob has a copy of it,
Bob can go in the other direction
and decrypt very easily.
He looks at the key and
applies the same rule.
If it's a zero, just copy it back up here.
If it's a one, copy the opposite.
So the two rules just
can, applying it twice
just cancels the effect of the encryption.
Does that make sense?
So it's provably, you know,
the weak link in all of this
is always the people, but mathematically,
if the people are behaving themselves,
mathematically, you can prove
this is perfectly secure
as long as the key is completely random.
There's no pattern to the zeros and ones.
It has to be as long as the message
because you have to
encrypt each single bit,
and you can never reuse it
because there'll be correlations
between subsequent messages if you do,
and so that's why it's
called a one-time pad, okay?
So that's basic classical encryption.
This is provably secure,
but it has a huge problem:
the key distribution problem.
The secret key, if Bob doesn't have it,
Alice has to send it to
Bob and it's a bit string
that's the same length as the message.
If she can't send the message securely,
how could she send the
secret key securely?
So maybe Bob, you know,
went back to somewhere in Virginia
and copied down what she had on,
Alice had on her one-time
pad and kept it with him,
hopefully for safekeeping
and nobody saw it,
then it'll work, but if,
if Alice and Bob are in
different corners of the globe
and haven't been able to do that,
you're stuck, because you can't
distribute the secret key.
It's the same problem as secretly
distributing the message.
Does that make sense?
Okay, so Eve could intercept
the telephone call,
the internet transmission,
the optical fiber transmission
and see what either the
message or the secret key are
and then just send it on
or observe it as it goes by
or send it on to Bob,
and Bob is none the wiser that
the eavesdropper is there.
It has compromised the channel.
So it turns out there's a solution
to the key distribution problem
if you use a quantum
version of bits, okay,
and this is a protocol that
was invented by my friend
Charlie Bennett and colleague
Gilles Brassard in 1984.
It was based on an older
idea called quantum money
invented by Steve Wiesner,
who was the son of the Wiesner
who was the MIT President.
Didn't, couldn't get it
published until much later
after these guys had done their protocol.
Okay, so we're gonna go through this.
There's lots to unpack here.
You gotta find out what is a quantum bit,
et cetera, et cetera, but here's,
I just want to do the big picture.
So, here's Alice in the Quantum
Institute, and this is Bob.
Bob is up the street in Jackson School.
Eve is somewhere in between,
and there are two ways we can communicate.
There's a public channel,
meaning it's a telephone
or internet connection,
something that's potentially,
whose security is not guaranteed, okay?
And then there's a quantum channel,
which I'm gonna have to
explain to you what it is,
and Eve has access
potentially to both channels,
and both channels are gonna
be part of the protocol.
So there's a part
that you don't need
quantum things to send.
You can just talk over the telephone
and anybody can listen in
and it can still be secure.
This is an interesting aspect of it,
because it has this quantum channel, okay?
And we're gonna try to be
consistent in our color coding.
So green will mean
public channel, anybody,
it means classical,
and anybody could in
principle be listening in,
and then the red will mean quantum channel
and blue will mean
classical or not quantum.
Okay, so here's the basic
idea I want you to hold onto
as we march through the complicated parts.
In quantum mechanics, if you observe,
that is measure the state of
a quantum system, it changes,
and it's the act of looking at something,
like shining light on it
and bouncing it to your eye,
the something is so tiny and fragile
that shining a little
light on it changes it.
That's roughly the idea.
And this BB84 protocol,
it's set up to detect
the presence of the
eavesdropper who is observing
what's being sent on the quantum channel.
There are gonna be quantum bits,
which I have to explain to
you, that are sent along here,
and if Eve looks at them,
makes a measurement of them
to see what secret key
is being sent to Bob,
they will unwittingly modify
the state of those bits
and corrupt what, the information
that's being sent to Bob,
but there's part of the
protocol is that Bob and Alice
will be able to detect
that that happened, okay,
and then call it off if
there's somebody there.
Okay, so again, information
is still physical,
even if it's quantum information.
Instead of storing
information in a, you know,
a big written zero or
one on a piece of paper
or a switch being open or closed,
we're gonna store information
in maybe the space
of a single atom or a single
particle of light, a photon.
And quantum mechanics teaches
us that the energy levels
of an atom are discreet,
they're quantized, they're not,
they don't vary continuously,
and you can label them then with integers,
and the lowest two you can
call state zero and one,
so if the energy is the lowest possible,
maybe that represents bit value zero,
and the first excited state
represents bit value one,
and there are many physical
systems that can hold this:
atoms, molecules, ions, photons.
Here at Yale, we work a lot
with electrical circuits,
superconducting electrical circuits.
Even small mechanical oscillators
can have quantized energy.
Okay, well, quantum bits are very, very,
very strange and mysterious,
so we have to, you know,
fasten your seat belts
and we have to think about
these very non-intuitive things.
So in addition to having
the possibility of being
in state zero or state one,
there's an infinite number,
a continuous range of states
called superposition states,
which are in some sense
intermediate between zero and one,
and yet if you measure
which state it's in,
it always comes out to be zero or one.
So, for the purposes of this protocol,
we're gonna use only four
states and we're gonna,
they're called polarization states
and we're gonna represent
them by arrows, so.
The qubit, the atom or
whatever is holding the qubit,
the arrow can point up or down
or to the right or to the left.
Those are the only four states
that we're gonna talk about.
If you look online at
videos about this protocol,
they used to talk about
photon polarizations,
and they used these lines
with arrows on both ends
and slopes like this, those four symbols,
but it just doesn't matter.
There's four symbols, okay?
And there's one bit of
information in here,
a zero or one, and yet
there are four states,
and it's because they
represent two different ways
to put the zero and one in there,
just like in the one-time pad,
you could start with a
a zero in the plain text
and represent it either as a zero or one
in the encrypted text,
randomly switching between the encodings.
There are two kinds of encoding.
Just like the secret
key in the one-time pad
can be a zero or one, those
are two different encodings,
we're gonna talk about a Z basis in coding
or an X basis in coding,
and so if Alice wants
to send a zero to Bob,
she can choose the Z encoding
and send him an up arrow,
or she could choose the X encoding
and send him an arrow
pointing to the right.
She wants to send a one,
and she randomly chooses this encoding.
She sends a down arrow.
She randomly chooses the X encoding.
She sends a left arrow, okay?
So the blue things are
the classical bits value
she wants to send to Bob,
and the red things are the
quantum states of our bits.
All right, so I think
we have an exercise now.
The conversion table is at the top,
and the exercise on the left
is you want to take the
classical bit and encode it
in the Z encoding into
one of those four arrows
or a zero and put it in the X encoding
with one of those four arrows,
and on the right you wanna
do the reverse process.
Here are the arrows.
You want to put zeros and ones here.
Does that make sense?
So take your time, feel
free to ask questions.
We have experts in the audience
who are standing by to assist you.
I think the next slide is the answer.
Okay, so you can check your answers there.
It's okay to be wrong and ask questions
about why you're wrong.
That's allowed.
That's the other important
sentence for every scientist.
I tell my students,
first thing when you get
out of bed in the morning,
say to yourself, could I be wrong?
The easiest person to fool is
yourself when doing science.
So, in the one-time pad, Alice
had flipped a bunch of coins
and had the secret key
and used those to randomly
change the encoding for, in each bit.
Here, Alice is gonna
do something different.
She's gonna randomly switch
between the Z encoding,
where the bits are up and
down, and the X encoding,
where they're left and right,
the polarizations, okay?
Now you say, well, that's not gonna help
because Bob can just look at the arrow
and see whether it's
up, down, right or left.
Well, it doesn't work that way.
The rules of quantum mechanics
don't let you know both of those things.
The rules of quantum mechanics say,
when Bob gets a qubit and
wants to see what its value is,
he has to make a decision.
He has to choose to see what the value is
in the Z polarization
to make what we call
a Z measurement, or X,
but he can't do both.
So if you know where a particle is,
you can't know how fast
it's going or vice versa.
This is like that.
If you know what the value of the bit is
when you measure it and make a Z,
I'm gonna show you a
picture of a Z measurement.
When you ask what is the value
of the qubit in the Z basis,
you remove the possibility
that you can find out
what it is in the X basis.
So it's like position and momentum.
There's a Heisenberg on
circuit principal connecting.
Yeah.
- [Student] And it's the choice
for each and every bit, or is it?
- Each and every bit.
We're gonna, Bob has to measure
and he has to make a choice 'cause he,
and you'll see, you know,
I'm gonna go through it,
so keep asking questions, but the first,
the thing you have to know
right now is he has a choice.
He can either measures in
the Z basis or the X basis.
Now we're gonna see what does that imply?
What happens when he does that?
Okay, so here's, Bob has some setting
on his measurement apparatus.
He can set it to Z or X, okay?
So he sets it to Z, and
it happens that Alice
has sent him a bunch
of bits in the Z basis,
so you see the arrows
are up and down, okay?
What happens?
Well, they just go through
and they're presented to Bob
with, you know, this represents a zero
and there's another zero
and there's a one, okay?
So when Bob looks at the
state, it doesn't get messed up
or changed, and Bob correctly
learns the bit value
that Alice sent, okay?
Something strange happens if
he chooses the wrong encoding.
If he decides to make an X measurement
when the polarization
is in the Z direction,
he gets random results.
Sometimes it's pointing to the right,
sometimes it's pointing
to the left, and so,
but he doesn't know that he's
randomly changed the state.
This would've been the result
if this polarization had been to the right
and passed through the measurement
and he got this unchanged.
He doesn't know that he changed
it, there's no way to tell,
so the bottom line is he's
unsure what Alice sent, okay?
It's unpredictable.
And so there's this strange
thing in quantum mechanics:
the results are random, but
it's not like, you know,
I have an envelope, I
try to flip the coin,
put a zero or one in a piece
of paper in the envelope
and handed it to me and there's definitely
either a zero or one in the envelope,
and when I open it, I see what it is.
That is, when you open
it, you see what you get.
In quantum mechanics, you
get what you see, you,
it doesn't have a value,
neither zero or one,
but when you look, the act
of looking brings a value
into existence: zero, one,
and if you ask is it
pointing in the X direction,
is it pointing horizontally, it always is,
sometimes to the right,
sometimes to the left.
If you ask, is it pointing up or down,
it always is when you measure it.
All right, so it works the other way too.
If Bob chooses to make an X measurement
and he happens to receive bits
that are pointing left and
right, it works fine, okay?
He correctly learns the classical
value bit that Alice sent.
But if he makes a Z measurement on qubits
that were encoded in the X basis,
he accidentally and unknowingly
randomly changes them, okay?
All right, so how can we use
these facts about nature,
which I just have to ask
you to accept at face value
because they're completely insane.
Alice is gonna, how can we use it?
So Alice is gonna randomly switch.
She flips a coin and decides
whether to use the Z basis
or the X basis, and she
does not tell Bob in advance
what she's gonna do, okay,
so there's no need for, you
know, communication of that.
That would be the same
as the key, all right?
So, Bob doesn't know if Alice
chose to encode in the
Z basis or the X basis,
so he doesn't know which basis to use
in order to measure to
get the right answer,
so he just guesses, okay?
He could guess a Z every
time or X every time,
or he could flip a coin,
and about half the time,
he'll by chance guess correctly
and half the time incorrectly, okay?
And so if he guesses correctly,
he gets the correct bit value.
If he guesses incorrectly, he
gets a random bit value, okay?
So there's a, even though it's random,
it might actually be the right one.
It might, you know, if it
was supposed to be zero,
maybe it comes out zero, so there's a 50%.
But he guesses incorrectly
only 50% of the time,
so that's where the 25% is.
Okay, we need two volunteers.
- [Florian] Who wants
to be YouTube famous,
to be recorded and posted,
so if you don't want
your image to be there.
- So you're Alice, you're Bob.
You need to compose a secret key, okay?
So we're gonna flip the coin.
If it's heads, write zero.
If it's tails, write one.
In fact, shall I flip it, or
you can do it, I don't care.
Heads is zero, I think I said, okay?
So, yeah.
(room laughs)
So by the way, some of you're gonna be.
- [Florian] He's gonna cheat already.
(room laughs)
- See, I told you it was the people.
One more, or is that it?
Okay, I can't count either.
Okay, so now you have the secret key.
Now you need to, let's see,
you have to do the encoding
using the table over there, okay?
Okay, measured, and Michelle,
we'll secretly check if you did it right.
Good.
Good, good.
All right, congratulations.
Okay.
Oh yeah, okay.
So I'm the person that makes
the measurement happen,
and it came out pointing to the left.
- Would that be a zero?
- Would?
Well, yeah, you can
decode it to ones or zeros
at the same time, if you want.
- Yes, yes, I see.
- Okay, and then what'd you
choose for the second one?
- X again.
- Okay, that was a mistake.
Tails.
That's a one.
Oh, that's an up.
No.
- So you mean left.
It's meant to be right or left.
Left.
- Oh yeah, okay.
Okay, sorry.
Yeah, okay, that's the one.
We should be doing this
so you guys can see it,
but all right, what'd you
pick for the third one?
- X again.
Okay.
Turns out it's the same, so you're, okay,
so it's pointing to the left.
You've got that one.
- Left is a what?
- You don't know that you've got it right.
I'm just fooling with you.
(room laughs)
Okay, what's the last one?
- Z.
- Z, okay.
It's up.
- Zero.
- Okay, all right, what'd
you get for the message?
- 0110.
- Okay, so you got that one wrong.
- Damn her.
(room laughs)
- And actually, how many, let's see.
So this, you chose the wrong basis here
and the wrong basis there,
but you accidentally
got the bit right, okay?
Here you chose the wrong
basis and got the bit wrong.
Here you chose the correct
basis and got it right, okay?
So it's not guaranteed.
He could've gotten lucky
and gotten it exactly right
or gotten them all wrong.
So here's what happened.
Just now, Alice sent Bob,
in this case we only did
four, but here let's say
here's a whole long
string of quantum bits.
She, here's the classical
bits she wants to send.
Here's the encoding basis
that she randomly chose
for each one, okay?
And so classical bit in the Z basis,
that's an up arrow.
Classical bit of zero in the X basis,
that's a right arrow.
Classical bit in one in the Z basis,
that's a down arrow, et cetera, okay?
So, these are the quantum bits
that Alice is sending to Bob.
Bob randomly chooses
what basis to measure in
and gets about half of them right.
The first three are right,
the ones in red are wrong.
Does that make sense?
Okay, so then when Bob
makes a measurement,
this one's correct,
so he correctly gets that
the polarization is up,
here he correctly gets that
it's to the right, here down.
Here he chose the wrong basis,
but accidentally got the,
oh wait, I haven't, okay, I just.
This is just a copy of
what was sent, so sorry,
I shouldn't have quite said that.
So we, the ones that, he got
about half of them wrong.
Well, he has to figure out
which half he got wrong, okay?
So this is the interesting part.
Alice publicly announces
the basis that he used
for each one through this public channel.
Tell everybody, even Eve.
She says, I used Z, X, Z,
X, Z, Z, X, X, Z, X, okay,
but she doesn't say which
bit she was encoding.
That is, she says it's
Z, but she doesn't say
whether it was up or down arrow.
She says it's X, but she doesn't say
whether it's left arrow
or right arrow, okay?
Now Bob, as soon as he hears
the public announcement
of her basis choices, he
knows which measurements
he did that were wrong.
Like here, she said this was an X
and he accidentally used a Z,
so he just drops that, he discards that,
he discards all the ones
that are wrong, okay?
And it's okay that Eve knows this.
Okay, is that clear?
All right, then Bob is now going to check
if there's an eavesdropper, okay?
He wants to, Bob, Alice
publicly announces among,
so Bob says, tells Alice
which ones he's thrown away,
which ones he happened to
use the right measurement,
and then Alice picks a small subset
of those that he got right,
so let's say this one and that one,
and she publicly announces
the actual bit value
that she sent, or the
cubic polarization, okay,
and Bob checks if he got the same thing.
If he got the same thing,
then it's probably true that
there's no eavesdropper,
because everything matched up.
If there's an eavesdropper,
she would've corrupted it randomly,
because she also has to guess
whether to measure in X or Z, okay?
It's not guaranteed, but if
this is a string of 100,000 bits
and Alice uses up 30 of
them for Bob to compare,
the chances of getting, failing
to detect the eavesdropper
in 30 tries is very, very small.
- [Student] I didn't,
I don't know if I fully grasp why that is.
Like how, why is it that Alice
checks the qubit with Bob
that that would enable
him to know if there's an?
- Well, I'll, I'm gonna
explain that separately.
I'm just kinda giving you
the why he's doing it, okay?
I'll answer that in a second.
Okay, so.
Okay, so now they've publicly announced
these bit values so they can't use those,
but all the remaining ones, like here,
Bob used the, made the
correct measurement,
has correctly gotten
the zero that she sent,
but nobody else except
Alice and Bob know that,
'cause there's no eavesdropper.
They've eliminated that possibility.
So they, first entry in
the secret key is one,
and then here it's a, sorry, a zero,
then it's one, here's a
zero and here's a one.
So you send many quantum bits
and you get a little
less than half of them
as your secret key,
and then you use it just
like a one-time pad.
You, this is just the secret
key in the one-time pad
where Alice can now send
on the public channel
her encrypted message,
and Bob has the secret key
to decrypt it, and it can be sent publicly
and Eve can hear it, but
she doesn't know what to do.
All right, so we're gonna
do this exercise now with,
assuming there's no eavesdropper,
and you're gonna break
up into teams of four.
- In the sheets you will choose.
I might do on that side so
they can actually see me.
In the first key, you will
choose a run up string
of zero and one, either
pinpoint or just writing them.
Then you would choose your
anchoring basis on X or Z,
and then you will do the
conversion authorization.
And then same thing.
- You will be using this table.
- Yes, and then you will
have a Michel measurements
who will come in and compare
if it's the same base that Bob picks,
you would get the same direction,
and if it's a different
one, you'll flip a coin
and write the wrong one, and
then you would convert that
and hopefully you will have the code
and you can compare how it matches that.
- Okay, so just to
review what we just did,
Alice picks a
classical bit string randomly,
an encoding basis randomly,
figures out what qubits to send from that,
then announces publicly
just the basis choice,
not the arrow directions
or the bit values.
Bob eliminates the ones where
he measured incorrectly.
Then, among the remaining
ones where Bob is sure
he should agree with Alice,
'cause he measured in the same basis,
they publicly compare a few,
and since there was no
eavesdropper in this example,
they should agree on those few and say,
oh, there's no eavesdropper,
and then get rid of those,
and the remaining ones, in this case one,
these one, zero, one and zero
are the secret key, okay?
If Bob's measurement, he chose
the right basis to measure,
so he should have gotten the
same thing that Alice sent,
but if they're different,
then they've detected the presence,
they've either made a
mistake, which does happen,
or they've detected the
presence of an eavesdropper
and they halt the protocol, okay?
The key isn't used to send the cryptogram
and the secret is safe,
although Bob doesn't know what it is.
They have to try again later.
Now, why does the eavesdropper
perturb the quantum channel,
change the state that Bob is receiving?
Well, because just like Bob,
she doesn't know which basis
in which to measure to
find out what Alice sent,
so she guesses randomly,
and when she guesses X
and Alice is sending in the Z basis,
she changes the results, okay?
Just like the problem that Bob had.
But, so when she passes it on to Bob,
in order to hide her presence,
she has changed the results,
but this protocol lets Bob and
Alice compare notes publicly
and see if Eve perturbed it.
So it's a very clever
protocol that involves,
it's secure even though it
involves public communication.
All right, so we're gonna try it again,
and some of the groups are
going to have an eavesdropper
and some of the groups are not,
and we know which is which,
we're going to tell you,
and then you guys are going
to go through the exercise
and tell us whether you think
there's an eavesdropper, okay?
So it's the same exercise,
but if Bob and Alice
don't agree on the ones that they select,
you have to assume
there's an eavesdropper.
You could get unlucky and not find out
The probability,
the failure probability.
If Bob and Alice sacrifice N of the bits
to see if they got the same result,
the probability of failure
is three-fourths to the N,
when if N is 30, that's
one chance in 10,000
that you would miss the eavesdropper.
If its N is 50, it's pretty small.
So, assuming you can
send hundreds of qubits,
it's not a problem, okay?
It's not guaranteed, but
it's exponentially unlikely
that you missed the eavesdropper.
- You're by group of four,
so the task would be
Alice, Bob, Eve and Michel.
So you all have a mission.
Alice and Bob needs to make an effort
to not hear what Michel and
Eve are doing in the middle,
so will try to stay in a corner,
like, try not to look too
much at what they're doing.
Each paper are numbered,
so you will have group one, group two,
and so what we're gonna do
is all the Alices will be lined up here,
all the Bobs will be lining here.
Hopefully try to like aim and recognize
who's your Bob, and
then Alice and Eve can,
sorry, Michel and Eve
would be in the middle
during the actual transaction.
I have a list of who's spying on who,
so I'll tell you that
based on your group number.
We were talking about,
a little bit earlier
about how some keypad logs.
I have the solution here.
I've lost it in the room
for five minutes, okay?
We didn't know where it was for a bit.
So like, no matter how much
encryption you do, stupid error,
human error will be also the
downfall of all this encryption
because we've lost the pads for a bit,
so you could have found
it and spied on us.
(room laughs)
And then the last thing we
have is a sheet of questions.
So basically, we are
asking three question.
The first one is how many of
Bob's basis match Alice's?
So we want to see like if
you had five, six, three.
How many bits did you reveal publicly?
So this is where you can gamble.
You can either say just one, two, three,
as many as you want, and
then you have to figure out
if you detect the eavesdropper.
So at the end, we want to
know if you've been spied on
and how many bits you can have.
- Right.
The more bit values you publicly reveal
so that Bob can check
if he got the answer,
the more likely you are to
detect the eavesdropper,
three-fourths to the end,
but fewer bits you have left
just for your secret key,
so that's the trade-off.
If you're feeling lucky,
you can just stop.
(room laughs)
- [Student A] Yeah, so
which state are you?
- [Student B] Okay, four I have zero.
(room cross-talks)
- Okay, so let's all sit down.
So we went through the whole process,
and hopefully we did it correctly in a way
that you didn't know if Eve
was spying on you or not,
so what happened is that she probably had
between four and six bits that
are correct in the string,
and then you had to choose
between one, two, three,
couple of bits that you can compare.
So I'm gonna call, we're
gonna call by order the group
and figure out who was spied on or not.
So I'm gonna call.
- Where's group one?
- Yeah, so let's have, let's have Bob.
Bob is usually the one who
will call that they're spied on
because Alice knows what makes sense.
Okay, group one, who's Bob one?
Were you spied on or not?
- [Student] What I guess or what?
- Yeah, what do you think?
- [Student] I guessed no.
- No, not spied on.
Well you were.
(room laughs)
So, that's the risk
and that's why we have
the probability of this.
Okay, who's Bob two?
Were you spied on or not?
- [Student] I don't think so.
- No, you were not, correct.
(room laughs)
- [Student] Nice.
- Group three, Bob three.
- [Student] That's me.
- Okay, were you spied on or not?
- [Student] We were, we were spied on.
- Yes, you were, and that
was an interesting case here
because they compared the first bits
and it was the same and they was like,
oh, we're not spied on, and
if they had stopped here,
Eve could have gotten the information.
They were like no, let's try another one,
and then the second bits were wrong,
and so that's why they
knew they were spied on.
Okay, group number four, Bob four?
Spied on or not?
- [Student] I decided not.
- That's correct.
Nobody listened to you.
Group five, Bob five.
- [Student] Yes, I was spied on.
- Yes, you're correct.
And I think we had
another group six, maybe?
- [Student] Yeah.
- Group six, were you spied on or not?
- [Student] Yes.
- No, you are not.
(room cross-talks)
Oh, okay.
- [Student A] Their Michel
overheard incorrectly
that Eve was a spy,
that Eve wasn't spying.
(room laughs)
- [Student B] Oops.
- These are the groups,
there were six groups, right,
I think, okay.
But that's a good example on like,
it's much easier to discard the whole key
if you have a doubt than
just using it regardless.
- Right, right.
Okay, super.
Thanks, Florian.
So here's the last slide.
This is just to illustrate for you
this in a real experiment.
So, China has this amazing
Micius satellite in orbit
about four years ago, I think, 2018,
and they have these telescopes
which follow the satellite
and lasers which send photons,
individual photons up at the satellite,
which then sends them back down,
in this case to Vienna to Anton
Zeilinger's lab in Vienna.
Anton is, won the Nobel Prize this year
for work on quantum entanglement,
which is kind of the
background behind this.
And they were able to send,
it's a moving satellite,
you know, it's a small target.
You gotta send photons up
and hit the detector there and so forth.
It's pretty complicated.
And they were able to send
a few thousand secret bits,
which were then used
to encode a phone call
between the President of,
Anton was the President of the
Austrian Academy of Sciences,
to the President of the
Chinese Academy of Sciences.
And here's a little animation.
Oh okay, there we go.
So there's a satellite
coming up over the horizon.
Here's the laser beam from the telescope,
and you see the dome turning as it goes.
This is a kind of time lapse thing.
That's why it's stretching out like that.
Very technologically complex
to send individual photons
up to this thing that's
moving 18,000 miles an hour
and then have it be able to send others
down from space to Vienna.
So this is the current state
of the art in this technology.
It's also been used in optical fiber.
There's a company in Europe, ID Quantique,
that Nicolas Gisin founded
that has done tests between
banks in Switzerland
sending encrypted bits
through optical fiber
over tens of kilometers.
This is the light.
The advantage of using the satellite
is you only have to go
through a thin layer
of the atmosphere, right?
The atmosphere is very, very thin.
It's just a few miles of air,
and then you go through back,
but the disadvantage is
you gotta hit that target,
and most of the photons will miss,
so they have to do this many times.
And then optical fiber is amazing.
You can send light through
it for several kilometers
without much of it being absorbed,
but if you want to send
it across the Pacific,
you have to have amplifiers
that can keep it going,
and those amplifiers ruin the classic,
the quantum part and make
it classical, so it's,
you have to build something
called a quantum repeater,
and we haven't, we're
learning how to do that now.
It's very, very hard.
So it's still very early
days for the technology,
but these, this particular
encoding, you know,
is in actual use and actually works.
So I hope you had fun
and learned a few things.
Thank you.
(room applauds)